The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is sort of two-fold.
It sort of goes back on
some of the other things
we've discussed with
the recent elections.
So I've recently been
following some of your stuff.
And there's evidence
that suggests
that you sort of predicted
the rise of the Trump campaign
about seven years ago.
And I'm sort of curious,
what was so different
about this election?
I presume you've seen the rise
of many presidential candidates
over the years.
And I'm sort of
curious to understand,
what sort of prompted
that speculation?
And the second
part of my question
sort of is looking more
so into the future.
So as we've discussed, America
is probably more polarized.
And it's sort of been--
in the past.
And there's s of this
idea that the clustering
of like-minded Americans
is tearing us apart.
So where do you see the
future of this nation going?
NOAM CHOMSKY:
Well, I mean, there
are many special factors
in the United States.
Societies are different.
But notice that what happened
in this election, what actually
happened in the 2016 election
is that the mainstream
establishment institutions
were basically destroyed.
The two major phenomena
in this election
were the Sanders campaign
among the Democrats
and the Trump campaign
among the Republicans.
And they were both
anti-establishment.
And the voters went that way.
If you take a look at polling
results, you can see it.
I mean, anger and
contempt for institutions
is just phenomenal.
If you ask people in
polls, do you have any--
what do you think
about Congress?
You know, 90% say they
should be all thrown out.
In fact, about the
only institution
that has any respect
is the military
because you're taught
somehow, the military
is defending us
from who knows what.
And the same is true in Europe.
Take a look at the French
election a couple of days ago.
The two candidates
were outsiders.
The political parties
barely participated.
Macron and Le Pen are from
outside the mainstream that
has run Europe for 50 years.
The center right and center
left parties are gone.
Same thing happened in
England with Brexit.
Same thing's happening in
other European countries.
We're seeing the phenomenon
all over the Western world
in which the centrist--
center left, center right--
institutions are under attack.
People are angry about them.
They hate them.
They think they're
not working for us.
And they're right.
That's the effect of
the neoliberal programs.
We're all subjected to the
same socioeconomic programs.
They've had a similar
effect everywhere.
They've led to
stagnation, decline,
undermining of public
services, inability--
Reagan's slogan, the state is
the problem, not the solution.
Let's turn it over to private
tyrannies, which make it worse.
That's happening.
Bits and pieces of that
are happening everywhere.
So it happened in
the United States
in its own particular way.
But notice that
it's two directions.
It's Sanders and Trump.
And I think in
many ways, they're
appealing to the
same sentiments.
And they could even converge.
A lot of the pop--
if you look at what
people believe,
the policies that they favor.
A lot of it's shared.
So for example,
across the population,
all the way over
to the Tea Party,
people think there ought to
be higher taxes on the rich.
Probably a majority
of the population
thinks there ought to
be national health care.
In fact, the support for
nationally guaranteed health
care has been so
high over the years,
that sometimes it's
almost hard to believe.
So in the late Reagan years,
for example, about 70%
of the population thought that
guaranteed national health care
ought to be in the
Constitution because it's
such an obvious demand.
About 40% of the population
thought it already
was in the Constitution.
Nobody knows what's
in the Constitution.
Just everything good must
be in the Constitution.
Since this is so obviously good,
it must be in the Constitution.
And right at the present,
the most recent polls
show somewhat over 50%
supporting national health
care.
When Obama's Affordable Care
Act was being pushed through,
at first one of the proposals,
one of the parts of it,
was what was called a
public option, which
means you could
choose if you wanted
to be part of a government
health care program.
About two thirds of the
population favored that,
but it was just thrown
out without discussion.
And in fact, if you
go case by case,
there's a lot of
similarity in the attitudes
about social/political issues.
Not necessarily cultural issues,
but social/political issues
among parts of the
population that appear
to be extremely polarized.
It's very interesting.
In England right now, if you
followed it, Jeremy Corbyn,
who's kind of a--
a little bit like
Sanders, is bitterly
attacked by the media,
including the liberal media,
like The Guardian and by the
parliamentary labor party.
Meaning the guys who sort of--
the elites who run the party.
They just came out with a--
I happened to be in England
a couple of days ago,
so I was reading
the British press.
They just came out with--
the labor party--
with their program,
which was just
lambasted by the media--
crazy, lunatic, insane.
It will destroy the labor party.
At the same time, polls
came out asking people
about the components
of the program.
They're all very popular.
Very strong support among the
population for the elements
of the program.
But attack on the party
that's proposing them.
And in particular, on Corbyn.
Serious activism and
organizing could overcome this.
I mean, you're
fighting elite elements
who have their own image of the
way they want society to go.
And in fact, there's quite a lot
of interesting things going on.
A lot of it is stuff that you
guys might be interested in.
It has to do with
data harvesting.
There's a company called
Cambridge Analytics, I think,
which is run by some
ultra-right billionaires.
Peter Thiel, the
guy who owns PayPal
and a bunch of other things.
Robert Mercer, who's a
big hedge fund manager,
multi-billionaire,
a couple of others.
What they've been doing--
and this essentially gave
the election to Trump--
is extremely careful
data analysis.
There's a ton of data
now from Facebook
and other things about
people's personal preferences
and attitudes and feelings.
Are you depressed,
all kinds of things.
And what they're doing is
looking carefully at this data
and analyzing it
to see if you can
find small numbers of people
in particular areas who
are vulnerable to one or
another form of manipulation.
And what they're doing
is trying to say, look.
If they kind of
tend to be liberal,
try to get them to
get so disillusioned
that they won't vote.
And if they tend to be, say,
traditionally conservative,
maybe religious or whatever,
try to get them to--
reach them individually
in ways which
will increase the
probability they'll
vote for the right wing.
This has small effects,
but the elections
are won on very small effects.
As you know, Trump
lost the popular vote
by a couple of million.
But in particular counties
that made the difference,
a couple of 100,000 votes
shifted the election.
In England, Brexit was the same.
They estimate about
maybe 600,000 votes.
The whole country switched.
Now, these companies using a lot
of complicated data processing
and statistics, and so
on, are working on ways
to try to control the
electoral process.
I mean, this is way
more important than any
of the nonsense about
the Russian hacking.
That's all garbage.
But this stuff is real.
And it's right in
front of our eyes.
It's the people we know.
MIT students going off
to work on these things.
And it has a big
effect on controlling
formal democratic systems.
This is Steve Bannon.
This is his image of how you
control the world, you know?
These are people
who are influential.
They have tons of money.
Deeply reactionary.
And they want to use
modern data processing.
You know, big data, statistical
analysis, and so on,
to see if you can just find
ways of swinging elections
by going after individual
vulnerabilities using
the massive data that people
provide through Google
and Facebook, and
all of this stuff.
Google and the rest of them
use it for advertisers,
so that advertisers can go
after you individually and say--
you try to get a book on Amazon
and they suggest 10 other books
you ought to buy because they've
got so much information on you
that they think, maybe I
can sort of sell this one.
That's going on all the time.
But here, it's right in the
middle of a political system.
And it's really significant.
Quite unlike the Russian
hacking story, this is real.
And it's not very far from us.
In fact, it's
happening right here.
There are things that
can be done about that.
Like exposing it for one thing.
These should be live issues,
I think, amongst students.
Do we want to devote our
lives to destroying democracy?
Maybe.